you posted a photo of you dressed as
Winnie the Pooh sitting in a mini
wrestling yeah what's that's you're
actually your dressing room here on the
lot why is why you a dress is Winnie the
Pooh and what is your obsession with a
wrestling ring Oh Conan that's just me
on the Thursday okay I mean I love
dressing like that I love wrestling I
was on @midnight they made me a
wrestling bed and I said I want to keep
it and that's what I love I love the
idea of two people fighting it out for
my enjoyment but they're actually
friends and they just end up hugging
each other and bang it out wait so you
don't like it if two wrestlers are
fighting each other and they hate each
other you don't like that no no I'm not
a barbarian Conan you want the people to
wrestle who really are friends I want
them to have no problem with each other
whatsoever be completely friends and be
like hey let's go kick the crap out of
each other so Ron will be happy so
that's what you like that's the kind of
wrestling that you enjoy that's what I'm
all about I'm trying to get a lady into
that wrestling ring so we can have a no
holds barred match yeah so far no takers
after this appearance you'll see it's
all gonna turn around would you could
you ever see yourself as a pro wrestler
oh I'm glad you asked
Conan I wouldn't be doing that if this
didn't work out I would be raw
the reckless Negro Funches
you know playing on the fears of anyone
would have already knocked something
over
we hide your weed and white women you've
got this would be fantastic I'd love to
see you wrestle but I love it - I get a
little iguana put it on my shoulder
what's that what's that okay it makes
perfect sense
he's gonna do the darkened eye on your
own bath water right now
absolutely hey thanks for watching be
sure to click subscribe to see even more
great Conan clips you may now return to
your pirated movies and creepy Japanese
pornography